[Music]
good evening and welcome to
cracking the girl code here at how the
light gets in in public and personal
life according to
girl code no woman can be wrong and
women must support other women to prove
their feminist credentials
but while some celebrate any woman in
power whether jacinda ardern and angela
merkel or even amy koenig barrett sarah
palin and pretty patel others argue that
like men women must be judged on how
they use their position
the gap between girl bosses and the
activists is widening
so should women support other women
independently of their qualities and
their approach or should we call out the
differences between exploiting the
patriarchy and overthrowing it in order
to achieve lasting progress
is feminism about being on the side of
women whoever they are and whatever they
stand for or has individualism taken
over the movement
with me to discuss this tonight are nina
power
who is a cultural critic social theorist
philosopher and translator
her interests lie primarily in art
feminism and politics
and she will soon be producing a new
book called what men want what do men
want what do men what question mark
question mark
with me on
my immediate left is maya oppenheim who
is the independent women's correspondent
it's a unique role and she is the only
woman's correspondent at any uk news
outlet maya covers news social policy
and global stories from a woman's angle
and finally
on my far left we've got hannah dawson
who is a historian of ideas currently
lecturing at the history of political
thought at king's college london she's a
fellow of the historical society and the
editor of the recent penguin book
the book of feminist writing that's
right good thank you
so there is our esteemed panel now
the question and i'm going to ask each
of our three contributors to lay out
their thoughts and answer to it
is should women always support women so
nina can we start with you
i'm really tempted just to say sure
unconditionally why not just as a joke
but no um
that would be ridiculous i think for me
feminism
if it means anything is the freedom to
fail and in fact women don't really have
uh any form of kind of emancipation or
existential
uh liberty unless they can make mistakes
uh publicly and privately and i mean
simone de beaufort makes his point in
the second sex in the 1940s um
but i really think it's it's absolutely
true because otherwise women are that
nothing other than victims or dependent
or they're more like children so i think
the sort of emancipation of women sort
of depends upon this becoming adult
which is to say to be able to to not
succeed um and that would therefore
include um
[ __ ] up at high level
so being a terrible prime minister for
example uh but i think also the ability
to publicly criticize each other is
extremely uh
necessary
um you know i on the other hand it's a
very very competitive and unpleasant
world and i think there are sort of
tendencies that we don't want to
encourage in anyone children men women
um which might be to do with our baser
instincts uh along the lines of kind of
envy and tearing people down
so i think we all need to be kind of
aware of those things as general human
tendencies and
i don't know to be more psychoanalytic
collectively about it actually i think a
lot of the time people present arguments
as if they're political but in fact
they're personal
and one of the things that feminism does
i think is introduce a whole
type of a range of discourse and a
historical perspective
that adds to our understanding of these
sort of forces and desires but women are
not exempt from criticism nor should
they ever be and i think when women get
things wrong
they should take it on the chin
okay thank you for that i'm going to
turn to maya now same question
uh i guess you just got to look at their
viewpoint you know not all women in
positions of power whether you're in a
footsie 100 boardroom or you're in you
know a cabinet meeting with boris
johnson not all women there want a more
egalitarian a less racist and more
feminist society so i mean i just think
you need to look at you know the
ideological standpoint of women in
positions of power like i'm not going to
stand here or sit here and say yeah i
love thatcher you know great that she
privatized all the social housing in
this country great that she you know
drove up poverty um
so yeah it's more complex than just kind
of this straight idea of let's get more
you know women into kind of seats in the
houses of parliament it's not a crude
thing that you can quantify it's not
about just about gender kind of
greater representation
um i guess you just need to ask the
question of what kind of world do we
want to live in do we want to live in a
world where between two and three women
are murdered every single week in the uk
that is by their former or their current
partner do we want to live in a world
where you know women routinely are
whacked in prison for simply having an
abortion that might be when they've got
pregnant you know from rape or incest
um
yeah do we want to live in a world where
i think every 16 hours a woman is shot
in shock by their former or their
current partner shot dead in america so
yeah but then you have to take the flip
side you know women in positions of
power disproportionately
suffer so much abuse you know rape flats
death threats whether that's women
journalists whether that's women
politicians whether that's celebrities
or then if you look at it from the human
rights angle often human rights
defenders if you look at the women that
are fighting for human rights around the
world if you look at the abuse that they
endure it's far more likely to be
personalized attacked they're far more
likely to have attacks on their children
they're far more likely to end up
withdrawing from public space because of
the abuse that they're experiencing so
yeah i think it's a complex question yes
women are not immune from criticism
that's a sexist condescending
patronizing view to take but also we
don't want to be abusing them as so
often happens
thank you very much for that hannah same
question
as maya's already kind of suggested that
strikes me as a as a kind of mad
question um and the answer has to be no
insofar as some women especially women
with power oppress other women those
women who are oppressors should be
called out um
i mean the idea that the hit that
feminism is about kind of unconditional
or automatic support for women as women
strikes me as
failing to understand
the history of feminism which is as much
about the conflict between women
historically as it is about the struggle
against patriarchy so if you look
throughout the history of feminism what
you find are women
calling out other women
for
their oppression so if you think back to
the very beginning of the so-called
first wave
of feminism in in america um the
declaration of seneca falls the
declaration of sentiments where
elizabeth cady stanton stood up and said
we declare it to be self-evident that
men and women are all created equal
she then went on to show that she
actually thought that some women were
more equal than other women and she
thought that suffrage for white women
should be fought for before suffrage for
black women
which prompted this kind of white
feminism prompted
sergeant a truth
a woman born into slavery escaped from
slavery to ask the question
entire woman
which points precisely to the way in
which feminists themselves have excluded
particular kinds of women from the
category of womanhood if you go on into
the second wave you think of another
iconic hero of the movement
betty friedan her amazing book the
feminist mystique uh she she also
thought
that um
lesbians were a problem for the movement
for feminism she thought that feminism
might not be so successful and she
called lesbians the lavender menace
and uh by the way uh lesbian feminists
responded to this by saying
[ __ ] you and um they created their own
group the radical lesbians and if you
just think now in our own time think
about pretty patel who who barry
mentioned
there we have a woman who
is uh
proposing a law that will refuse asylum
to the most some of the most vulnerable
women on this planet who are refugee
women trafficked women
so i think it's clear that women oppress
women that the history of feminism has
been as much about the resistance to
this as it is to the resistance to um
patriarchy and that true solidarity um
has to be about liberation for all
justice for all not just some and those
with power
which is why in the words of audre lorde
she says i am not free while any other
woman is unfree
hannah thank you and thank you all for
the taking those uh three minutes to set
out uh your view it's often assumed i
think that when we use the word feminism
it will mean the same on everybody's
lips but that's probably not right so i
wondered if we could begin with you nina
and just just ask
you know can we get clearer about what
feminism means or what you mean by
feminism
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas